[Música]
bienvenidos a esta emisión especial en
la que france24 les mostrará el
cubrimiento en vivo del discurso del
estado de la unión que dora del
presidente joe biden esta es la primera
vez que da este tipo de discurso y lo
hará precisamente ante el congreso para
informarle lo que ha hecho en su
administración en los más de 400 días
que llevo al frente de la casa blanca
esperaba que el mandatario se centre en
los tres grandes retos que han
enfrentado como presidente y que además
son históricos se trata de la guerra en
ucrania la pandemia del coi 19 y un
aumento histórico en la inflación de su
país y alcanzado cifras que no se veían
hace 40 años para eso conectaremos en
vivo con la señal desde washington y así
escucharemos lo que dice joe biden luego
de que el luego de que mandatario
termine su intervención tendremos un
análisis con nuestros invitados
johansson que nos director del grupo de
investigación en relaciones
internacionales
américa latina e integración de la
facultad de ciencias políticas y
relaciones internacionales de la
pontificia universidad javeriana
colombia también estaremos con roxana
juárez especialista de seguridad
nacional y fuerzas armadas además
tendremos una conexión en vivo con
nuestro corresponsal cristóbal vázquez
quien está en washington para ver antes
de que el presidente joe biden de su
discurso veamos el siguiente informe en
el que les damos los datos más
relevantes de qué pasará en este
discurso del estado de la unión
es una tradición consagrada en la
constitución de eeuu el discurso anual
del presidente sobre el estado de la
unión los padres fundadores
establecieron que el presidente debe
informar al congreso sobre el estado del
país y recomendar las medidas que
consideren necesarias y oportunas pero
no fue sino hasta el siglo pasado que lo
que era un simple reporte escrito se
transformó en un espectáculo moderno de
poderío presidencial además de las dos
cámaras del congreso se invita a la
corte suprema al cuerpo diplomático a la
junta de jefes del estado mayor y a todo
el gabinete del presidente excepto al
superviviente designado el sucesor
oficial del presidente en caso de
catástrofe el primer estado de la unión
de joe biden coincide con una coyuntura
delicada una población exhausta por la
pandemia preocupada por la creciente
inflación por el aumento del gas y la
guerra en ucrania
escrich aún no hay duda de que el
discurso será un poco diferente de lo
que habría sido hace unos meses siempre
hay referencias a la seguridad nacional
en cada discurso sobre el estado de la
unión pero cada uno refleja un momento
en el tiempo observer fax
by then tendrá que enfrentarse al
balance de sus meses de mandato
intentando celebrar éxitos como el
nombramiento de la primera mujer
afroestadounidense a la corte suprema- y
reconociendo las dificultades que
persisten además de la mención a ucrania
se espera que el presidente insista en
su estancada agenda económica interna y
que detalle sus planes para atajar la
inflación y la criminalidad una encuesta
reciente de eivissa news y el washington
post revela que sólo el 37 por ciento de
los estadounidenses aprueba el trabajo
de byd en algunos miembros del partido
demócrata esperan que el discurso
propulsar a la difícil presidencia
eso es precisamente lo que veremos y con
este discurso joe biden logra propulsar
su presidencia y la cantidad de
popularidad que tiene vamos en este
momento hasta washington dónde está
nuestro corresponsal cristóbal vázquez
con él ya habíamos hablado previamente
pero vamos a recordar precisamente con
cristóbal cuáles son los temas que se
espera que joe biden trate durante su
discurso del estado de la unión
cristóbal cuéntenos un poco más de qué
se espera esta noche en washington
sí pues ya entró en el senado en pleno
ya entró también la cámara en pleno ya
entraron los jueces de la corte suprema
en pleno al recinto donde se llevará a
cabo el primer estado de la unión el
primer discurso de yo bailén tras un año
en la casa blanca se espera tres temas
tres temas específicos que ya se ha
mencionado la pandemia la economía y
ucrania entrando con el presidente
entrará una representante a la cámara
victoria spartz que es ucraniana ya
nación ucrania llegó a eeuu en el 2010
se casó en europa con el estadounidense
severo eeuu y el representante a la
cámara por el estado de indiana estará
presente de hecho está vestida con los
colores ucranianos una invitada especial
también estará en este recinto es la
embajadora por ucrania acá en washington
ella se había mención se había referido
a la situación en ucrania hace unos días
había llamado a eeuu a que diera más
apoyo
y en ayuda humanitaria y eso
precisamente será uno de los puntos que
aborde obviamente el presidente joe
biden en este primer discurso será
pedirle al congreso que facilite más
ayuda en temas de armas y en temas de
ayuda humanitaria de cara a ésta a este
conflicto que ésta es que está
ocurriendo nuestro momento en ucrania el
presidente pues entregará un mensaje
claro a los estadounidenses y es estemos
preparados para el costo económico que
va a implicar las sanciones y que va a
implicar esta guerra que está avanzando
cada día más en ucrania y pues que tiene
más repercusiones delante en europa sino
en eeuu en segundos estaremos viendo ya
a la presidente yo voy de entrar a este
recinto dar este discurso que según la
casa blanca será cada vez pues menos más
corto se está estábamos acostumbrados a
discursos pues bastante largos por parte
del ex presidente don 8 antes se espera
que ese discurso pues sea breve pero sea
conciso y aborde sus temas la pandemia
la inflación y ucrania también hay que
resaltar
que yo baile pues empezará a mencionar
los logros que ha tenido en este primer
año sus logros para mitigar el tema de
la pandemia y pues es sus logros en
cuanto ayuda militar que eeuu en el
último año ha dado a ucrania es mayor a
los mil millones de dólares y eso pues
seguramente lo resaltará el presidente
yo bailé resaltando que es el país que
más ayuda militar ha dado a ucrania este
año y que pues ha preparado obviamente
ha
hablado de michelle es que para poder
resistir estos días desde invasión de
rusia si cristóbal y precisamente como
usted decía el presidente joe biden ya
está entrando al congreso como lo
veíamos previamente en las imágenes que
les estábamos mostrando en directo y
además de estos tres temas que usted nos
mencionó y de que eeuu le está dando mil
millones de dólares a ucrania otra de
las cosas que se espera tal como se lo
mencionó es la inflación podría el
presidente de joe biden presentar un
proyecto para combatir esta que está
dispara o un proyecto de salud mental
también cristóbal no lo voy a dejar
responder vamos a interrumpir para ir en
directo con la señal desde washington y
escuchar lo que dice el presidente joe
biden en su discurso de la unión del
estado
miembros del congreso tengo el gran
honor
de presentarles al presidente de los
eeuu
muchas gracias
muchas gracias a todos
[Aplausos]
muchas muchas gracias a todos
por favor
muchas gracias
señora presidenta señora vicepresidenta
primera dama al segundo caballero
miembros del congreso y del gabinete
jueces de la corte suprema
mayor los estadounidenses el año pasado
el kobe 19 no se paró este año
finalmente estamos juntos de nuevo esta
noche
esta noche nos reunimos mientras los
republicanos demócratas dependientes
bajo ese vamos a etiqueta pero como
estadounidenses con un deber con el uno
con el otro con eeuu con el pueblo con
la constitución
y una alta determinación de que la
libertad siempre vencer a la tiranía
[Aplausos]
hace seis días
ruso vladimir putin trato de sacudir las
bases del mundo libre tratando de romper
las
doblarlas de muchas maneras pero hizo un
pésimo cálculo pensó que podía llegar a
ucrania y que la guerra se iba a acabar
en vez de eso se enfrentó con un muro de
fortaleza que jamás anticipó y ni
siquiera imaginó se enfrentó con el
pueblo ucraniano
el presidente es el esquí
[Aplausos]
para cada crear ya no para cada camino
determinado o valiente su acción inspira
al mundo grupos de ciudadanos que
bloquean a tanques con sus cuerpos de
estudiantes retirados a profesores se ha
convertido en soldados para defender su
tierra y en esta lucha el presidente de
lenski dijo en su discurso al parlamento
europeo que la luz vencerá a la
oscuridad
el embajador ucraniano de las naciones
unidas está ahí con la primera dama
por favor denos ver si está por ahí
ponerse de pie y mantener una señal
inequívoca al mundo y ucrania
muchas gracias
muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
una gran determinación un gran ejemplo
nosotros los estados unidos de américa
estamos del lado del pueblo ucraniano
durante nuestra historia hemos aprendido
esta lección cuando los dictadores no
pagar un precio por su agresión causan
mucho más caos siguen avanzando y el
costo de las amenazas a eeuu y al resto
del mundo sigue aumentando por eso es
que la alianza de la otan fue creada
para asegurar la paz y la estabilidad en
europa tras la segunda guerra mundial
los eeuu es un miembro junto con otras
29 naciones y eso importa
la diplomacia estadounidense importa la
determinación estadounidense importa el
último ataque de putin sobre ucrania fue
premeditado y totalmente no provocado el
rechazo reiterada de los esfuerzos de
información él pensó que el occidente y
que la otan no responderían él pensó que
podía dividirnos en casa en esta cámara
en esta nación él pensó que podía
dividirnos en europa también pero putin
estaba equivocado nosotros estamos
listos y estamos unidos
eso fue lo que hicimos permanecimos
unidos nos preparamos con mucho cuidado
pasamos meses construyendo colisiones
con otras naciones amantes de la
libertad también el continente americano
africano para confrontar a putin con
muchos de ustedes he pasado muchas horas
tratando de unificar a nuestros aliados
europeos
compartimos con el mundo con
anticipación lo que sabíamos que putin
estaba planeando
y les dijimos cómo iba a tratar de
falsificar y justificar su agresión
nosotros contrarrestamos las mentiras
rusas con la verdad y ahora ahora que ha
actuado
el mundo libre es haciendo que sea
responsable junto con otros 27 miembros
de la unión europea incluyendo a francia
alemania italia así como países como el
reino unido canadá japón corea australia
nueva zelanda y muchos otros incluida
suiza
están causándole daños a rusia y están
respaldando al pueblo ucraniano putin
ahora está aislado del mundo mucho más
de lo que nunca había estado
juntos
junto con nuestros aliados ahora estamos
ejerciendo unas fuertes sanciones
económicas estamos
sacando a los grandes bancos de rusia
del sistema financiero sectorial e
impidiendo que el banco central usted
entienda el rublo ruso
haciendo
que el fondo de guerra es más de seis
mil millones de dólares no esté operando
hemos acabado el acceso ruso a la
tecnología que podría
hemos debilitado su ejército de aquí en
años por venir y esta noche le digo a
los oligarcas rusos ya los líderes
corruptos que amasaron millones de
dólares tras este régimen que ya no más
los eeuu
estoy hablando en serio
los eeuu el departamento de justicia ha
creado una tarjeta de una fuerza de
tarea dedicada para perseguir a los
oligarcas rusos estamos junto con
aliados europeos
encontrando sus yates en sus
apartamentos sus jets privados
estamos yendo a buscarlos
esta noche voy a anunciar que nos
uniremos con esos aliados al cerrar el
espacio a todas las aeronaves rusas
aislando mucho más a rusia y agregándole
una presión superior a su economía
él no tiene idea de lo que viene
el rubio ya ha perdido 30% de su valor
el mercado bursátil ruso ha perdido 40%
de su valor y el comercio sigue
suspendido la economía rusa está decaída
y putin es el único responsable junto
con nuestros aliados le brindaremos
respaldo a los ucranianos en su lucha
por la libertad asistencia militar
asistencia económica humanitaria también
estamos dando más de 1000 millones de
dólares de asistencia directa o grant y
seguiremos ayudando al pueblo ucraniano
mientras defienden a su país ayudaremos
a aliviar su sufrimiento
pero quiero ser claro
nuestras fuerzas no
entrarán no van a entrar en conflicto
con fuerzas rusas en ucrania nuestras
fuerzas no van a ir a europa combatir en
ucrania sino defender nuestros aliados
se notan en el evento en que putin
decide a seguir moviéndose hacia el
occidente por ese propósito hemos
movilizado tropas estadounidenses
escuadrones aéreos navíos para proteger
a los países de la otan incluyendo a
polonia rumanía lituania letonia y
estonia y dejado bastante claro que los
estados unidos y nuestros aliados
defenderán cada pulgada del territorio
que haga parte de la otan con toda la
fuerza de nuestro poder colectivo cada
pulgada
[Aplausos]
y tenemos bastante claro que los
ingenieros están luchando de vuelta con
mucho coraje pero los próximos días
semanas y meses van a ser difíciles para
ellos putin ha liberado un caos violento
pero aunque pueda ganar en el campo de
batalla pagará un precio bastante largo
en el bastante alto en el largo plazo
libra por libra
el pueblo cráneo seguirá luchando por lo
que tiene han conocido 30 años de
independencia en los han vivido y esto
ha mostrado que ellos no van a tolerar a
nadie que intente quitarle su país o que
intente retroceder lo a todos los
estadounidenses voy a ser honesto con
ustedes como un promete hacerlo siempre
un dictador ruso que invade otro país
ha causado alrededor del mundo
un montón de daño y me voy a asegurar de
que las sanciones haga blanco en la
economía rusa utilizaremos cada
herramienta nuestra disposición para
proteger a los negocios y consumidores
estadounidenses esta noche voy a
anunciar que los eeuu ha trabajado con
30 otros países
para liberar 60 millones de barriles de
reservas estratégicas del petróleo en
todo el mundo eeuu ha hecho ese esfuerzo
vamos a sacar 30 millones de los
reservas y estamos listos para hacer
mucho más de ser necesario unidos junto
a nuestros aliados estos pasos nos
ayudan a disminuir los precios del gas y
la gasolina aquí en casa pero sé que la
noticia de lo que está pasando pueden
alarma los estadounidenses yo solo
quiero que sepan que vamos a estar bien
vamos a estar bien cuando la historia de
esta era sea escrita la guerra de putin
en ucrania ahora ha dejado a rusia más
débil al resto del mundo mucho más
fuerte
[Aplausos]
aunque no debió haber requerido algo tan
terrible para que el mundo viera lo que
está en juego ahora todo el mundo lo
puede ver claramente vemos la unidad
entre líderes de las naciones
una europa mucho más unificada un
occidente más unificado vemos unidad
entre ellos la gente que se reúne las
ciudades y grandes multitudes alrededor
del mundo incluyendo rusia para
manifestar su respaldo por el pueblo de
ucrania la batalla entre la democracia y
la autocracia las democracias están
poniéndose a la altura el mundo está
eligiendo claramente el lado de la paz y
la seguridad
este es el examen verdadero y va a tomar
tiempo así que sigamos esperándonos de
la gran voluntad del pueblo ucraniano
a nuestros compañeros y ucranianos
estadounidenses que forman ese fuerte
lazo que une las naciones estamos del
lado de ustedes del lado ustedes putin
puede haber acercado aquí en contactos
pero jamás ganará los corazones y las
mentes del pueblo ucraniano
jamás entenderá el amor y la libertad
jamás debilitará
y la determinación del mundo libre
nos hemos reunido hoy en eeuu que ha
pasado por dos de los años más duros que
ha enfrentado la nación la pandemia ha
estado castigando
y hay muchas familias que están viviendo
pago a pago tratando de mantener el alto
costo de la casa de las casas de los
servicios de la comida entiendo como
muchos de ustedes mi padre tuvo que
llevar su dejar su hogar en scranton
principal ya para buscar trabajo como
ustedes yo crecí en una familia que
sentía el alto precio de la comida esto
es un impacto bastante grande por eso es
que una de las primeras cosas que hice
como presidente fue tratar de pasar el
plan de rescate estadounidense porque la
gente estaba sufriendo
necesitábamos actuar y lo hicimos
pocas piezas de iniciativas han hecho
tanto en un momento tan crítico de
nuestra historia para sacarnos de una
crisis
hemos cumplido con los esfuerzos de cómo
vacunar a la producción y competir el
cubit y si lo hemos entregado ayuda
financiera a decenas de millones de
estadounidenses
vemos ayuda a poner comida en sus mesas
recuerdan esas filas de autos que
estaban esperando por horas solamente
para recibir alguna caja de comida esto
a corto también los costos de la salud y
como mi padre solía decir le dio a la
gente solamente un poquito de aire para
respirar
a diferencia de los cortes fiscales de
millones de dólares pasados para
terminar la administración
este plan de rescate
este plan de rescate estadounidense
ayudó a la gente trabajadora y no es
buena de atrás
damas y caballeros
y esto funcionó
esto funcionó
eso funcionó
creamos trabajos muchos trabajos de
hecho nuestra economía creó más de 6.5
millones de trabajos apenas el año
pasado más trabajos en un año
que nunca antes en la historia de los
eeuu de américa
la economía creció a una tasa de 5.7 la
más fuerte en 40 años y el primer paso
es llevar este cambio fundamental en
nuestra economía
que ha trabajado para que ha funcionado
para gente trabajadora es la primera
función por mucho tiempo de los años
anteriores se nos dijo que un corte
fiscal para la gente de arriba ayudaría
a beneficiar al resto pero esa teoría
llevó a una economía mucho más débil o
en crecimiento más bajo bajos salarios
mayores déficits y una mayor brecha
entre la gente de arriba y el resto
en casi un siglo miren la vicepresidente
de jarvis y yo aspiramos al cardo y
entiendo que teníamos desacuerdos
fundamentales en esto pero aspiramos
bajo una nueva visión económica por eeuu
y pierda en eeuu educar a los
estadounidenses aumente la fuerza de
trabajo consigue la economía desde abajo
y de los lados
porque sabemos
[Aplausos]
porque sabemos que cuando la clase media
crece
los pobres suben y a los ricos les va
bien
eeuu obliga a tener las mejores vías
aeropuertos y puentes en la tierra y
ahora nuestra infraestructura es la
número 3 en el mundo no podremos
competir por los trabajos del siglo 21
si no arreglamos esto por eso es que es
tan importante
aprobar la ley bipartidista de
infraestructura y yo le agradezco a mis
compañeros republicanos que se han unido
a mí
[Aplausos]
en la inversión y la reconstrucción de
eeuu
la mayor inversión de la historia del
país
es un esfuerzo bipartidista y quiero
agradecerle a los miembros de ambos
países que han trabajado de ambos
partidos para que han trabajado para
hacerlo suceder ahora estamos hablando
de una década de infraestructura
y miren
eso
esto va a transformar eeuu nos va a
poner en el camino
de la competencia económica del siglo 21
y nos enfrentaremos con el resto del
mundo particularmente con china le he
dicho a chikin ping que nunca ha sido
una buena apuesta apostar en contra del
pueblo estadounidense nosotros vamos a
crear buenos trabajos para millones de
estadounidenses
modernizar aeropuertos vías caminos
fluviales y lo vamos a hacer
protegiendo el medio ambiente
vamos a construir una red nacional
de millones de cargas eléctricas vamos a
reemplazar las
las construcciones de plomo para que la
gente pueda tomar agua con seguridad en
casa y en las escuelas también vamos a
proveer
[Aplausos]
internet accesible de alta velocidad
para todo el mundo
urbanos suburbanos comunidades viajeras
44 mil proyectos ya han sido anunciados
muchos de esos en sus distritos y esta
noche estoy anunciando que este año
vamos a empezar a arreglar más de 65 mil
millas de villas y al menos 100 puentes
damas y caballeros
cuando utilizamos el dinero de los
contribuyentes para reconstruir eeuu lo
haremos comprando estadounidense compren
productos estadounidenses respalden los
trabajos estadounidenses
el gobierno federal
gasta cerca de 600 millones
de dobles para mantener al país seguro y
hay una deuda larga en estos libros para
asegurarnos que sus dineros respalden a
los negocios estadounidenses cada
administración demócrata republicana
dice que lo va a hacer pero nosotros
estamos haciendo lo realmente
compraremos estadounidense para
asegurarnos de que todo desde
las construcciones en aeroplanos hasta
las vías férreas se han estadounidense
desde el principio hasta el final cada
parte
pero damas y caballeros
para competir por los trabajos del
futuro también necesitamos nivelar el
campo de juego con china y con otros
competidores por eso es que es tan
importante
aprobar el acta de evasión bipartidista
que logra que lograra
inversiones récord en manufactura
estadounidense necesitamos invertir al
menos 2 por ciento de nuestro producto
bruto en investigación y desarrollo
china lo está haciendo de generarles un
ejemplo porque es tan importante
si ustedes viajan 20 millas al este de
columbus ohio se encontrarán con mil
acres vacías y esto no parece mucho pero
si uno mira de cerca uno ve un campo
donde es posible soñar la tierra en la
que puede ser construido el futuro eeuu
ahí es donde intel la compañía que ayudó
a construir silicon valley va a
construir una planta de 20.000 millones
de dólares producir que producirá
semiconductores del estado del arte todo
va a estar en un solo lugar diez mil
trabajos nuevos en esas fábricas el
trabajo base es de unos 135 mil dólares
al año
es de las más factores más sofisticadas
del mundo
para hacer chips de computadores de la
talla de un dedo meñique para alimentar
la vida cotidiana de smartphones a
internet tecnologías que uno han sido
inventadas por eso solamente el inicio
el presidente de intel pad singer está
aquí esta noche a esta pad ponte de pie
por favor
y no verme y me dijo que estaban listos
para aumentar su inversión de 20 mil
millones a 100 mil minutos
esa será la mayor inversión en
manufactura de la historia
estadounidense
y lo único que se espera es que se
aprueba esta ley no esperemos más se
envíe la me siento yo que yo la firmaré
y realmente vamos a despegar de una gran
manera
damas y caballeros
[Música]
intel no está solo
[Aplausos]
hay algo que está ocurriendo en eeuu
miren alrededor
verán una historia increíble un renacer
del orgullo
de ver en los productos hecho en eeuu la
revitalización de la manufactura
estadounidense los las compañías están
eligiendo construir fábricas acá cuando
hace algunos años hubieran ido a otro
país eso es lo que está pasando ahora
fuerte está invirtiendo 11 mil millones
de dólares para crear vehículos
eléctricos creando miles de trabajos de
todo el país ya me está haciendo la
mejor inversión en su país 7 mil
millones para construir vehículos
electrónicos eléctricos que crean 4000
trabajos en michigan
360 mil nuevos trabajos en manufactura
en general fueron creados en eeuu nada
más el año pasado
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
alimentado por la gente que conocido
como yo yo varias
generaciones de trabajadores de
servicios en pittsburgh yo está por ahí
muchas gracias hombre
[Aplausos]
como decía el senador de ohio ser el
brown
chevron dice que es momento de acabar
con esa etiqueta del cinturón del óxido
bueno es momento de ver lo que solía
llamar hacer que el rover se convierta
en el hogar
de la red surgió del resurgimiento de la
manufactura y tenemos
todos los puntos partes no se comían
muchas familias todavía siguen luchando
con los pagos la inflación está
quitándoles las ganancias que creían que
podrían utilizar y yo lo entiendo por
eso es que mi mayor prioridad es hacer
que los precios se controlen miren
nuestra economía volvió mucho mucho más
rápido que cualquiera predijo pero la
pandemia enfrentó a los negocios y los
negocios no podían contratar gente
debido a la pandemia para mantener la
producción en sus fábricas
no teníamos gente que estuviera haciendo
esos cimientos que estaban los edificios
porque la fábrica estaba cerrada el
pánico también y rompió la
cadenas u visos mundial las fábricas
cerraron cuando eso sucede requiere más
tiempo a hacer bienes y llevarlos a los
almacenamientos los precios aumentan
miren los carros el año pasado un tercio
de toda la inversión fue debida a la
venta de autos no había suficiente
semiconductores para hacer los carros
que la gente quería comprar y saben que
los precios aumentaron muchísimo
especialmente los usados
entonces tenemos una elección
una manera de luchar contra infecciones
bajar los salarios y hacer que he estado
en un sonido sea pobre y creo que tengo
una mejor idea para luchar la impresión
bajen los costos no los salarios
damas y caballeros
eso significa que hay que hacer más
autos y semiconductores en eeuu más
infraestructura más innovación en eeuu
más bienes que se mueven más rápido y
más barato en eeuu más trabajos donde se
pueda ganar un buen estilo de vida en
eeuu en vez de confiar en cadenas de
suministro y sacras hagámoslo en eeuu
miren
y los economistas
y
llaman a esto la cada vez yo les llamo a
esto construir un mejor eeuu
mi plan para combatir la inflación
y disminuirá los costos y el déficit
17 de laureados con el nobel dicen que
mi plan podrá reducir la inflación
líderes empresarios y creo que la
mayoría de estadounidenses también
respaldan este plan es ese plan en
primer lugar
disminuir el costo de las drogas de
prescripción
pagamos más
[Aplausos]
por el mismo medicamento producido por
la misma compañía en eeuu que cualquier
otro país del mundo miren la insulina 1
de 10 estadounidenses sufre de diabetes
en virginia conocí un niño de 13 años
ese joven que está ahí yo soy deivid
él y su padre tienen diabetes tipo 1
esto significa que necesitan insulina
cada día
[Aplausos]
esto cuesta cerca de 10 dólares por
ampolleta es el costo de las
farmacéuticas pero las compañías le
cobran a las familias como las de
georgia al menos 30 veces esa esa
cantidad de hablé con la mamá de joshua
imagínense lo que es ver a su hijo que
necesita esta medicina para estar
saludable y no tener idea de cómo poder
pagar por ello
que le hace es una familia que le hace
eso a la dignidad a la capacidad de ver
a el hijo a los ojos de ser el padre que
uno espera hacer realmente piensan en
eso eso es lo que yo pienso
ayer
esta noche esta noche pero ayer
cumpleaños feliz cumpleaños por cierto
para joshua
y 200 mil jóvenes más con diabetes tipo
1 por favor
pongamos el precio máximo a 30 dólares
al mes para que cualquier persona pueda
comprarlo
y las compañías de medicamentos harán
buenos negocios todavía habrá un margen
correcto
sé que hay grandes desacuerdos en este
tema pero
asumamos medicare y negociamos el precio
de los medicamentos de prescripción
[Aplausos]
ya se ha establecido el precio para los
medicamentos de los veteranos miren el
plan de rescate estadounidenses ha
ayudado millones de familias que estaban
en medicare a ahorrar miles de dólares
al año cerremos esta brecha hagamos que
estos ahorros sean permanentes en
segundo lugar
[Aplausos]
disminuyamos los costos energéticos para
las familias un promedio de 500 dólares
al combatir el cambio climático
creamos un
radio fiscal a los negocios para que
busquen la eficiencia energética
duplicamos la producción de energía
limpia solar eólica bajemos los costos
de los precios eléctricos ahorrando al
menos 80 dólares al mes que no haya que
pagar en la bomba de gasolina damas y
caballeros
en tercer lugar
[Aplausos]
lo tercero que podemos hacer para
cambiar el xantar de vida para las
familias trabajadoras es disminuir el
costo del cuidado infantil
disminuyamos esto
si ustedes viven en una gran ciudad en
eeuu pagan a hasta 14 mil dólares al año
por cuidado infantil por niño
yo fui un padre soltero por cinco años y
criaba dos hijos y tuve muchísima ayuda
una mamá un papá
un hermano y una hermana que realmente
me ayudaron pero las familias de clase
media no deberían tener que pagar más de
7% de su ingreso para cuidar a sus hijos
mi plan
mi plan disminuirá los costos
del cuidado infantil para la mayoría de
estas familias
y ayudará a padres incluyendo a millones
de mujeres que abandonaron la fuerza
logrando entrar para nadie porque no
podían
permitirse el cuidado infantil para
poder volver al trabajo eso generará
crecimiento económico en plan no se
detiene ahí también incluye el cuidado
el hogar a largo plazo
más soluciones habitacionales
todo eso bajará el costo para las
familias no
debe decir esto de nuevo nadie que se
gane menos
d
puede que me equivoque
pero imagino que si tomamos un voto
secreto en este salón y todos acordamos
que este sistema fiscal más justo
tenemos que arreglarlo no estoy buscando
castigar a nadie pero hagamos que las
corporaciones y los estadounidenses
américa adinerados paguen la parte justa
miren el año pasado
el año pasado
cris coons y tom carper
y esta congresista distinguida todos
venimos de la tierra bueno del eeuu
corporativo
en nuestro estado y muchas más
corporaciones y seguir ganando 36 años
en fila el punto es que ellos también
entienden que uno tiene que pagar la
parte justa el año pasado 55 de las
compañías del fortune five andrés
ganaron cuenta mil millones de dólares
en ganancias bueno y pagaron cero en
impuestos federales miren esto esto no
es justo por eso es que propuse un
impuesto mínimo del 15 por ciento de
estas corporaciones
por eso es que en el g7 y estos
encuentros
pude ser útil y
130 países acordaron una tasa mínima de
un impuesto global para que las
compañías no pueden abandonar pagar los
impuestos en casa al enviar producción
en otros países y eliminar millones de
dólares fiscales por eso es que quiero
cerrar los vacíos legales para los muy
adinerados que no pagan o pagan una tasa
menor a la de un profesor y un bombero
eso es mi plan pero poder entrar en
detalles después la economía crecerá
veremos los costos a las familias que
estamos esperando que hagamos que esto
pase todos sabemos que tenemos que hacer
cambios
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
y mientras estamos en ello confirmen a
mí nominado a la reserva federal y eso
juega un rol crítico en combatir la
inflación
mi plan no solamente bajará costos para
las familias y les dará una oportunidad
sino que bajará el déficit la
administración previa no solamente
aumentó el déficit con los recortes
fiscales a los adinerados sino que
vino a los observadores el
de esos fondos bueno recuerdan que
tenemos esos debates sobre si esos
observadores deberían poder ver día a
día cuánto dinero se estaba gastando a
dónde estaba yendo hacia el lugar
apropiado en mi administración los
observadores están de vuelta
[Aplausos]
y vamos a perseguir a los criminales que
robaron miles de millones de dólares de
ayuda que buscaban ayudar a los pequeños
negocios hoy o ser honesto estoy
anunciando que el departamento de
justicia nominar a un fiscal para
perseguir el fraude durante la pandemia
miren
creo que todos estamos de acuerdo en
esto gracias al final de este año el
déficit bajará a menos de la mitad de lo
que era cuando yo asumí el cargo el
único presidente que cortara el déficit
por más de un billón de dólares en un
solo año bajando el costo también se
exige más competencia y yo soy un
capitalista pero el capitalismo sin
competencia no es capitalismo el
capitalismo sin competencia es
explotación
aumenta las ganancias
las corporaciones deben competir
sus ganancias aumentan y los precios
aumentan cuando no tiene que competir
los pequeños negocio las pequeñas
familias debo decirle esto a muchos
amigos republicanos
hay cuatro
tenemos cuatro y no paga mucho más
y mucho más porque solamente cuatro
fábricas que produzcan algo de carne
miren lo que pase con la gente que
mueven los bienes por el océano los
transportistas en el océano durante la
pandemia a cerca de media docena aumentó
sus costos por más de 1000 por ciento
hicieron ganancias récord y esta noche
anuncio que vamos a perseguir a esas
compañías que están aumentando los
precios y castigando los consumidores
[Aplausos]
mientras las firmas de wall street se
toman más hogares de cuidado estos
hogares están disminuyendo y los costos
aumentan eso debe terminar ahora
medicare va a aumentar los estándares
para estos hogares de cuidado asegurarse
que los seres queridos puedan recibir un
buen servicio y van a observarlo de
cerca también vamos a recortar los
costos y mantener la economía fuerte de
los trabajadores una oportunidad
dándoles más entrenamiento basados en
habilidades no solamente encargos
aprobemos el acta de justicia en el pago
aumentemos el salario mínimo a 15
dólares la hora y extendemos la
extensión fiscal a dos niños para que
nadie tenga que criar a una familia en
la pobreza
aumentemos
también el patrocinio para las
universidades tradicionalmente a precio
de unidades y la primera dama
dice que este es el secreto mejor
guardado de eeuu y es las universidades
comunitarias pasemos a él probar cuando
la mayoría de trabajadores quieren
formar un sindicato no deberían poder
detenerse cuando invertimos en nuestros
trabajadores y construimos la economía
de abajo para arriba podemos hacer algo
que no hemos hecho en mucho tiempo
construir un mejor eeuu por más de dos
años el comida impactado cada decisión
en nuestras vidas y la vida de esta
nación y yo sé que ustedes están
cansados y frustrados
exhaustos
el tipo de daño
mucha gente tiene que mirar a una mesa
vacía cuando cena porque perdieron a
alguien pero también sé esto debido al
progreso que ya hemos logrado debido a
la resiliencia de ustedes en las
herramientas que hemos brindado desde el
congreso esta noche puedo decir que
estamos dando pasos hacia adelante con
seguridad
de vuelta a una rutina mucho más normal
hemos alcanzado un nuevo momento en la
lucha contra el cob y 19 donde los casos
severos han disminuido a un nivel no
visto desde julio del año pasado hace
unos cuantos días
el cdc
emitió una nueva línea guía sobre los
tapabocas bajo las normales la mayoría
estadounidenses la mayoría del país
ahora puede salir sin máscara y basados
en algunas proyecciones
[Aplausos]
más
y más gente en el país encontrar ese
punto de las próximas semanas gracias al
progreso que hemos logrado el año pasado
del covent 19 ya no necesita ya no
controlan nuestras vidas sé que algunos
hablan de vivir con el hobby 19 pero
esta noche yo digo
que nunca aceptaremos vivir con el joven
19 seguiremos combatiendo el virus
como combatimos otras enfermedades y ya
que este virus muta y se disemina
tenemos que seguir en guardia hay pasos
cuatro pasos de sentido común mientras
seguimos de aquí en adelante en primer
lugar sigan protegidos sean protegidos
con vacunas y tratamientos
ahora tenemos una gran eficiencia las
vacunas si hay refuerzos hay un mayor
grado de protección nunca nos rendiremos
a la hora de querer vacunar los
estadounidenses sé que a los padres que
tienen hijos menor de 5 quieren ver una
vacuna autorizada los científicos están
trabajando muy duro para lograrlo y
tenemos muchas vacunas listas para
cuando lo hagan ya
también estamos listos con tratamientos
antivirales y si usted se enferma con
kobe 19 la vacuna de facer reduce las
posibilidades de ir a la clínica en un
90% por una enfermedad grave
tenemos dos píldoras que nadie más en el
mundo en facer está trabajando tiempo
extra para consumir de píldoras sms
y más del doble el próximo mes y ahora
estamos lanzando la prueba
una iniciativa de pros para que la gente
pueda recibir pruebas si reciben un
resultado positivo van a recibir estas
píldoras 5 salvo no
[Aplausos]
si hay alguna otra vulnerabilidad
tenemos tratamientos y tenemos tapabocas
gratis de buena calidad no estamos
ignorando ni dejando a nadie atrás de
aquí en adelante en cuanto a las pruebas
hemos hecho cientos de miles de pruebas
las hemos puesto disponibles y las
pueden ordenar gratuitamente a sus casas
y ya hemos ordenado si ya ustedes han
ordenado pruebas gratis esta noche
ustedes pueden ordenar otro grupo de
pruebas
vayan a kobe test punto gov a partir del
otra semana y fue recibir las pruebas en
segundo lugar debemos prepararnos para
nuevas variantes
en el pasado nos hemos lo hemos mejorado
detectando nuevas variantes si es
necesario desarrollar nuevas vacunas en
podrían salir en 100 días en mes de
meses o años
si el congreso aprueba estos fondos
tendremos más rondas de pruebas más
caras
y píldoras si se necesitan yo lo puedo
prometer que no viene una nueva variante
pero puedo prometerles queremos todo
nuestro poder para estar listos si
sucede en tercer lugar
podemos acabar con el cierre de escuelas
y negocios tenemos las herramientas
necesarias
es momento de que eeuu vuelva a trabajar
y que nuestros centros estén llenos de
gente que la gente que trabaja en casa
se sienta más segura y puede volver a la
oficina estamos haciendo eso en el
gobierno federal la gran mayoría de
trabajadores federales
están trabajando de nuevo en persona
nuestras escuelas están abiertas
mantengamos lo así los dos niños
necesitan estar en la escuela
[Aplausos]
75% de los autos estadounidenses ya
están vacunados la hospitalización ha
crecido en 77% la mayoría
estadounidenses pueden quitarse las
máscaras y permanecer en el salón de
clases
y proceder con seguridad logramos esto
porque hemos dado vacunas gratis
tratamientos pruebas y tapabocas por
supuesto seguir con esto cuesta dinero y
estoy seguro que nos vamos a volver a
ver y voy a mandar una petición pronto
al congreso la gran mayoría de
estadounidenses han utilizado estas
herramientas
y bueno podríamos necesitarlo de nuevo
entonces espero que el congreso apruebe
estas medidas rápidamente cuarto lugar
seguiremos vacunando el mundo hemos
enviado 470 millones de vacunas a 120
países más de cualquier otra nación en
el mundo
y no nos detendremos
porque uno no puede construir un muro
suficientemente alto para mantener
afuera
la vacuna puede detener la diseminación
de estas enfermedades
hemos perdido tanto con el commit 19
[Música]
tiempo el uno con el otro pero mucho
peor la pérdida de vida veamos este
momento y elijamos
un reinicio dejemos de ver el cuit como
una división partidista veámoslo por lo
que es una enfermedad terrible
dejemos de vernos el uno del otro como
enemigos empecemos a vernos por como
somos compañeros estadounidenses miren
no podemos cambiarlo / es que hemos
estado esto ha pasado por buen tiempo
pero podemos cambiar cómo proceder de
aquí en adelante sobre kobe y 19 otros
temas que tenemos que enfrentar juntos
visite recientemente el departamento de
policía nueva york tras el funeral del
oficial wilber mora y jason ribera
ellos estamos respondiendo la llamada al
911 cuando un hombre los mató con un
arma robada el oficial mujeres tenía 87
años el oficial rivero tenía 22 años
ambos eran dominicanos estadounidenses
que crecieron en las mismas calles
que luego eligieron patrullar como
oficiales de policía hable con sus
familias les dije que siempre estaríamos
en deuda por sus sacrificios y
seguiremos con su misión de restaurar la
confianza y la seguridad que cada
comunidad merece como algunos de ustedes
que han estado por aquí un buen tiempo
he trabajado con ustedes en estos temas
por un buen tiempo sé lo que funciona
investigar la prevención del crimen y
la policía comunitaria policías que
conozcan el barrio policías que puedan
restaurar la confianza y la seguridad no
abandonemos nuestras calles no tenemos
que elegir entre la seguridad de la
igualdad reunámonos para proteger a la
comunidad para hacer que las fuerzas de
seguridad sean responsables por eso es
que el departamento de justicia ha
requerido cámaras corporales
vetar agresiones por parte de oficiales
por eso es que el plan de rescate
estadounidense
provee 350 de millón de dólares para que
ciudades estados y condados puedan
contratar a mayor a más policías y
puedan invertir en una estrategia
diferente
estrategias comprobadas como
mensajeros confiables romper el ciclo de
drama y de violencia dar las niños
esperanza a todos debemos acordar que la
respuesta no es darle quitarle fondos a
la policía sino darles fondos
darles fondos
[Aplausos]
darles recursos y entrenamiento recursos
y entrenamientos que necesitan para
proteger a sus comunidades le pedí a los
demócratas y republicanos por igual que
aprueben este presupuesto para mantener
nuestros barrios seguros haremos todo lo
que esté en el poder para acabar con el
tráfico de armas de armas fantasma que
se pueden comprar en casa que se puede
ensamblar en casa sin números seriales
no se pueden hacer le pedí al congreso
que aprobara medidas comprobadas para
recibir violencia corp con armas
permitir la revisión de antecedentes
porque alguien en la lista de
terroristas puede comprar un arma porque
por qué
damas y caballeros
inventar armas de asalto con magacines
con gran capacidad de los proveedores
gente vistiendo
chalecos de qué hablar
y la única industria que no puede ser
demandada en eeuu en la industria
armamentística imagínense que hubiéramos
hecho eso con las manufacturas de tabaco
estas leyes no impiden la segunda
enmienda estas leyes salvan vidas el
derecho más fundamental en eeuu el
derecho es el derecho a votar y que ese
voto sea contado y miren este derecho
está bajo salto
he estado tras estado hay nuevas leyes
que no solamente suprimir el voto hemos
estado ahí sino que subvierten una
elección entera no podemos permitir que
eso suceda esta noche le pido al senado
que apruebe
el acta de libertad de voto el acta de
joe louis el acta para el voto y
mientras están en ellos
aprueben la ley que controla quién
patrocina nuestras elecciones mir en
esta noche quisiera honrar a alguien que
dedicó su vida para servir a su país al
juez brian un veterano del ejército un
constitucionalista
juez que está a punto de retirarse la
cosa suprema pues braier gracias por su
servicio muchas gracias
por favor pónganse de pie desde que lo
vean gracias
todos sabemos
y sin importar cuál sea le dirige a
todos sabemos que uno una de las
responsabilidad más importante es bajo
la constitución del presidente es no
mirar a alguien para que sirva en la
corte suprema de eeuu
y lo hice hace cuatro días denominado
[Música]
a que está en brawn jackson
una de nuestras mejores mentes legales
que seguirá el legado de excelencia
después bryant
una gran litigante
una gran fiscal de una familia de
educadores de escuela pública y de
oficios de policía ella es una persona
que construye consensos desde que fue
nominada ha recibido una gran cantidad
respaldo incluyendo
el de la orden fraterna de policías y
jueces con respaldo republicano y
demócrata damas y caballeros y vamos a
avanzar en la libertad de la justicia
tenemos que asegurar nuestras fronteras
y arreglar el sistema migratorio también
[Aplausos]
y como pueden imaginar creo que podemos
hacer ambos
en nuestra frontera hemos instalado
nuevas tecnologías como escáners de alta
fidelidad para detectar tráfico de lo
que hacemos creado fronteras en méxico y
guatemala para atrapar a más traficantes
de personas hemos ubicado jueces
migratorios en grandes números para que
las familias que huyen de la persecución
pueden hacer oír sus casos y para que
haya una audiencia legítima estamos
monitoreando estamos creando compromisos
y respaldando socios en centroamérica y
suramérica para alojar más refugiados y
asegurar sus propias fronteras podemos
hacer esto mientras tenemos la antorcha
de libertad encendida que ha traído
muchos migrantes a esta tierra muchos de
sus antepasados y los míos dieron
también tenemos que dar un camino a la
ciudadanía de los dreamers a los
trabajadores esenciales a los que tienen
un estatus temporal tenemos que revisar
nuestras leyes para que los negocios
tengan los trabajadores que necesitan
las familias no tienen que esperar
décadas para reunirse no solamente lo
correcto es lo más inteligente para la
economía por eso es que la reforma
migratoria está respaldada por todos
desde
legisladores desde la cámara del
comercio hasta los sindicatos hagámoslo
de una vez por todas
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
a avanzar en la libertad de la justicia
también requiere proteger los derechos
de las mujeres el derecho constitucional
reafirmado por robert white ha
funcionado por menos por medio siglo
pero no ha sido atacado como hasta ahora
tenemos que proteger también el exceso
de salud bronce preservar el derecho a
la mujer de elegir y tenemos que
progresar en el cuidado a la madre en
los servicios de salud
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
para las comunidades es el eje que más
tenemos que aprobar el acta bipartidista
de igualdad lleve en la migratorio
las leyes que atacan a las personas
transgénero ya sus familias es cerrada y
lo he dicho
se lo dije el año pasado a nuestros
jóvenes transgénero estoy del lado de
ustedes para que ustedes puedan ser sí
mismos y pueden alcanzar su potencial
damas y caballeros
como acabo de demostrar
parece que no estamos de acuerdo siempre
pero estamos de acuerdo más cosas de las
que reconocemos
firme 80 actas bipartidistas el año
pasado desde el prevenir cierres
gubernamentales proteger a los
estadounidenses de ser víctimas de
crímenes de odio reformar la justicia y
ahora vamos a estar fortaleciendo
el acta de derechos de las mujeres que
hemos estado empujando por 30 años eso
es muy importante
es muy importante para nosotros mostrar
mostrarla en la nación que podemos
reunirnos y hacer cosas grandes
tenemos que
podemos hacer cuatro cosas muy
importantes en primer lugar
y vencer la epidemia de opiáceos
hay tanto que podemos hacer
[Aplausos]
aumentar el patrocinio a la prevención a
los tratamientos a la recuperación
acabar las reglas caducas e impedir que
los doctores prescriban tratamientos
e impedir el flujo de drogas ilícitas al
trabajar con las fuerzas de seguridad
para perseguir a los traficantes si
están sufriendo de adicción ustedes
saben deben saber que no están solos yo
creo en la recuperación y celebro los 23
millones 23 millones de estadounidenses
que están recuperándose en segundo lugar
enfrentemos la salud mental
especialmente entre los niños cuya vida
y cuya educación ha sido trastocada el
plan de rescate estado ni salida de
escuela de dinero las escuelas para que
haya psicólogos que ayuden con los temas
de aprendizaje
las escuelas pueden hacer eso tienen el
dinero pueden tenerlo y podemos hacer
esto pueden ustedes permitirse de ser
mentores o profesores los niños ya
estaban sufriendo antes de la pandemia
el bullying el drama los daños de las
redes sociales
como francés haugen que está aquí hoy ha
mostrado
debemos debemos hacer que las
plataformas de redes sociales sean
responsables por los experimentos
nacionales que están haciendo entre
nuestros niños para obtener dinero
damas y caballeros
muchas gracias
muchas gracias por el coraje que usted
ha mostrado
es momento de fortalecer la protección
de la privacidad
respetar publicidad dirigida a niños
impedir que haya recolección de datos
personales sobre los niños hagamos que
todos los estadounidenses
tengan los servicios mental de salud
mental que necesitan más gente debe
poder buscar ayuda
y debe haber una paridad entre la salud
mental y la física y debe ser tratado
así en nuestros seguros médicos miren
[Aplausos]
la tercera parte de esa agenda es el
respaldo a nuestros veteranos
los veteranos son la columna vertebral
son la espina dorsal de ese país son lo
mejor que tenemos
siempre he creído
que tenemos una obligación sagrada con
aquellos que hemos enviado a la guerra y
tenemos que cuidarlos cuando vuelven a
casa mi administración ha brindado
asistencia entrenamiento laboral
habitas calzas y bueno liberación de
deudas para nuestras tropas de irak y en
afganistán que enfrentan los muchos
peligros uno
es estar en bases y bueno respirar aires
tóxicos muchos de ustedes han estado ahí
yo he ido a irak y afganistán al menos
40 veces
esta esta basura incinerada
la basura
médica la gasolina de los jets tanto más
ellos vuelven a casa muchas de las
personas mejor entrenadas y mejor estado
físico pero no vuelven a hacer lo mismo
dolores de cabeza mareos calambres o un
cáncer
que los puede poner
en un féretro yo sé
uno de ellos uno de esos soldados fue mi
hijo el mayor
yo no sé si
la caldera en donde él estaba bueno
antes en kosovo en irak fue la causa de
su cáncer cerebral y la enfermedad de
tantas tropas más pero tengo un gran
compromiso de entender lo más que
podamos es un gran compromiso con las
familias tales como la de daniel
robinson de ohio
viuda del sargento robinson de la
guardia nacional médico de combate con
software en irak que estuvo cerca a
vagar apenas a metros de caldera espero
daniel está con nosotros aquí hoy
ellos solían ir a haber partidos de ohio
state de fútbol americano
[Aplausos]
a él le encantaba construir figuras de
lego con su hija pero el cáncer por
exposición a estos vapores acabó con sus
pulmones y con su cuerpo daniel dice que
era un luchador hasta el final él no
sabía cómo dejar de luchar
ella tampoco a través de su dolor
encontró propósito
empiezo a exigir que lo hiciéramos mejor
hoy daniel vamos a hacerlo mejor
la oficina de veteranos
está creando está entendiendo maneras de
vincular estas enfermedades con gases
tóxicos para que los venenos tengan más
beneficios y hoy estoy anunciando que
vamos a aumentar la elegibilidad de los
veteranos para tratar estos cánceres
respiratorios también le pido al
congreso que pase la ley para asegurarse
de que los veteranos que sufren de estas
enfermedades finalmente reciban los
beneficios
y la salud el servicio de salud completo
que requieren
en cuarto y último lugar
acabemos con el cáncer como lo conocemos
esto es un tema personal
[Aplausos]
esto es personal para mí para hill y
para cámara y para tantos de ustedes
tantos de ustedes han perdido a alguien
que aman esposo esposa hijo hija madre
padre el cáncer es la segunda causa
de muerte en eeuu y la primera es la
enfermedad cardíaca del año el mes
pasado
y anunció que iba a respaldar el plan
por la vacuna contra el cáncer vamos a
cortar las muertes de cáncer al menos en
un 50% de aquí a los próximos 25 años y
creo que podemos hacerlo mejor
convirtamos el cáncer de sentencias de
muerte enfermedades tratables debe haber
más respaldo para pacientes y familias
para llegar allá le pidió al congreso
que patrocine lo que llamo ahora page
[Aplausos]
investigación avanza proyectos de
investigación avanzada una agencia
dedicada a esto
fue creado a través de proyectos
liderados en dar para que llevaron la
internet al gps a tantas cosas para
hacer que nuestras fuerzas estuviera más
segura y pudieran
hacer la guerra con mayor claridad al
para tendrás sólo un propósito llegar a
descubrimientos en el cáncer el
alzheimer y las diabetes y mucho más una
agenda de unidad para la nación podemos
hacer estas cosas está en nuestro poder
y no su alcance
y no veo una ventana partidista para
nadie en esas cosas vayan los
estadounidenses esta noche
nos reunimos en ese espacio sagrado
una ciudadela de la democracia en este
capitolio
generación tras generación de eeuu han
evadido grandes inquietudes con una gran
voluntad y han hecho cosas grandes hemos
luchado por la libertad hemos expandido
la libertad
hemos debatido al totalitarismo y al
terror hemos construido al país más
fuerte más libre y más pero espero que
el mundo ha conocido este es el momento
nuestro momento de responsabilidad
nuestra prueba de conciencia y de
resolución bajo la historia misma es en
este momento
que el carácter de esta generación es
formado nuestro propósito ha sido
hallado nuestro futuro está forjado yo
creo que esta nación
nosotros cumpliremos con esta prueba
proteger bueno de libertad
expandiremos la justicia y la
oportunidad y salvaremos a la democracia
sin importar los duros lo duro que haya
sido a los ciertos momentos no tengo
tanto optimismo como ahora porque sé que
el futuro está a nuestro alcance porque
sé que no hay nada
más allá de nuestras capacidades somos
la única nación en la tierra que siempre
ha convertido cada crisis en una
oportunidad la única nación que puede
ser definida por una sola palabra
posibilidades en esa noche
en nuestro año 245 como naciones vengo a
reportarle al estado de la unión mi
reporte es este
el estado de la unión es fuerte porque
ustedes el pueblo estadounidense son
fuertes
[Aplausos]
somos fuertes hoy
somos más fuertes hoy de lo que éramos
hace un año
y seremos más fuertes de aquí a un año
de lo que somos hoy es este es nuestro
momento
de enfrentar y superar los desafíos de
nuestras vidas lo haremos como un solo
pueblo solo eeuu los eeuu de américa
dios los bendiga a todos y que dios
proteja nuestras tropas gracias
acabamos de escuchar al presidente de
estadounidense joe biden dar su primer
discurso del estado de la unión que duró
exactamente una hora en el el mandatario
trató cuatro temas principales comenzó
abordando el tema de ucrania y la
invasión rusa en este territorio
continuó pasando la economía
estadounidense luego se refirió a la
pandemia y finalmente hizo un recuento
de varios temas a los que le pidió al
congreso que lo respaldarán como lo
decía anteriormente baiden comenzó
hablando de la guerra en ucrania allí
dio una importante noticia y es que
estados unidos y sus aliados cerraran el
espacio aéreo a todas las aeronaves
rusas y luego la administración federal
de aviación del departamento de
transporte de eeuu confirmó que esta
medida entrará totalmente en vigor a
partir de mañana miércoles hacia el
final del día otra de las noticias es
que bailén enfatizó una idea que había
dado previamente y es que eeuu no
enviará tropas a ucrania puntualmente el
mandatario afirmó que los
estadounidenses no combatirá
directamente con los rusos aunque
advirtió que defenderán cada pulgada del
territorio colectivo de la otan como lo
afirmó en estas mismas palabras esto
quiere decir que eeuu va a reforzar sus
fuerzas militares dentro de la alianza
militar especialmente en países como
polonia que hace parte de la otan sin
embargo según las palabras de biden los
estadounidenses y sus tropas no entrarán
a ucrania él también afirmó que hizo una
alianza con 30 países para liberar 60
millones de barriles de petróleo en todo
el mundo y así combatir la presión
económica que tiene rusia dada su
capacidad de gas y de petróleo en
términos de economía le pidió al
congreso que aprobara la ley de
infraestructura que es la mayor
inversión en la historia del país y que
daría 12 billones de dólares para
renovar vías puertos marítimos entre
otros
bardem afirmó que es la manera que
necesitan para nivelar el campo de juego
con china y se refirió a este gigante
asiático- afirmando que la ley de
infraestructura le permitiría a eeuu
estar en igualdad de condiciones con
este país también hizo promesas para
reducir el costo de las familias
trabajadoras dentro de ellas afirmó que
durante su administración se disminuirá
el precio de los medicamentos de
prescripción también el costo energético
por familia y también el costo del
cuidado infantil además el mandatario
estadounidense defendió su idea de
imponerle un impuesto mínimo del 15 por
ciento a las grandes empresas otra de
las grandes noticias que dio en su
discurso el mandatario es que nominará a
un fiscal para perseguir el fraude
durante la pandemia su intención es
perseguir a las compañías también que
aumentan los precios y castigan a los
consumidores como lo dijo en sus propias
palabras en noticias de la pandemia
joe biden dijo que seguirán combatiendo
el virus y que tal como el virus muta
tendremos que seguir manteniendo la
guardia él defendió una de las ideas que
ha sido más criticadas por los
republicanos
y es mantener las escuelas abiertas y
que las oficinas sean de manera
presencial en este sentido afirmó que en
eeuu la hospitalización por kobe 19 ha
caído un 67 por ciento que el 65 por
ciento de los adultos estadounidenses ya
están vacunados y que además eeuu es el
país que más vacunas ha distribuido
contra el joven 19 en todo el mundo
según bain en eeuu ha proporcionado 470
millones de vacunas enviadas a 120
países en otros temas le pidió al
congreso estadounidense que aprobaran
dos proyectos de ley que impulsan los
demócratas y a los cuales los
republicanos se han opuesto hasta ahora
el primero de ellos es la ley el
proyecto de ley de libertad para votar
que amplía el acceso al voto lucha
contra el sabotaje y también aumenta la
transparencia en la financiación entre
otras medidas el segundo es el proyecto
de ley de avances de derechos
electorales john lewis que pretende
actualizar la ley de derechos
electorales de
1965 que combatía el racismo en las
elecciones locales y estatales además
joe biden se refirió a uno de los temas
que más ha defendido incluso durante su
campaña presidencial antes de llegar a
la casa blanca y es que le pidió a los
congresistas que lo respaldarán en una
reforma migratoria en sus palabras
mencionó que deben arreglar las
fronteras y el sistema migratorio
también defendió un proyecto de ley de
salud mental para los retirados de las
fuerzas militares y se refirió a un tema
que él afirmó que es bastante personal
para él y es la lucha contra el cáncer y
es que joe biden jill biden perdieron a
su hijo mayor quien murió por cáncer
cerebral y desde entonces baiden ha
librado una batalla que dice que es
personal él le pidió al congreso un
respaldo para el programa alfa con el
que arfa con el que pretende lograr
avances que no pueden lograrse
fácilmente a través de la investigación
tradicional su intención reducir a la
mitad la muerte por cáncer la gran
conclusión de joe biden es que el estado
de la unión es fuerte porque los
estadounidenses son fuertes
estas palabras cerró su discurso para
encontrar un respaldo total frente a su
gobierno y especialmente frente a sus
labores ante ucrania vamos entonces
hasta washington donde está nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
una de las preguntas que se está
haciendo gran parte de los
estadounidenses es que tanto le puede
ayudar este discurso al presidente wyden
para aumentar su popularidad que como
ustedes nos lo decía antes desde
noviembre no ha subido a más del 40 por
ciento
exactamente creo que yo trato de enfocar
este discurso en el rol principal que
tiene que jugar eeuu de cara a esta
crisis en europa por la inversión de
rusia y ucrania el rol de liderazgo que
ha jugado además en el último año con el
más de los más de 1000 millones de
dólares que ha donado eeuu a ucrania con
para la asistencia militar yo bailén
resaltó la cantidad de veces que él
informó al mundo y hace lencia ucrania
que se prepararon porque venía un ataque
ruso y pues repitió varias veces que él
tenía la inteligencia que la compartió a
todo el mundo y pues en varias ocasiones
selenski varios países europeos pues
trataron de contrarrestar de minimizar
estos alertas de eeuu y él insistió en
que a pesar de todo esto eeuu ha dado el
apoyo no solamente militar sino también
humanitario que ha requerido que está
pidiendo por lo michelle es que
presidente ucraniano es de resaltar en
el tema de ucrania el anuncio que hace
hoy oval del que seguramente pues
a apoyo bipartidista es el anuncio de
que cierra el cielo cierra el espacio
aéreo para los aviones rusos esta medida
se había adoptado en las últimas horas
por la unión europea y eeuu se suma
entonces a esta medida para que ningún
avión ruso pueda sobrevolar espacio
aéreo estadounidense esto bloquea
bastante la economía de rusia en temas
comerciales y esto este anuncio también
adicionalmente con lo que dijo sobre
putin diciendo que está putin más
aislado que nunca y que sus acciones han
hecho que europa y eeuu se unan aún más
que occidente esté cada vez más unido en
cuanto su team avanza más en ucrania
frente a estos anuncios lo que terminó
pasando en la sala plena del senado es
que de la cámara representantes es que
tantos senadores demócratas como como
republicanos se pararon y aplaudieron
durante varios segundos eso no se veía
y no se vio durante
mucho tiempo sobre todo en la
administración
de el pasado presidente de donald trump
la división la polarización en eeuu ha
sido un tema bastante recurrente
bastante alarmante y el y este preciso
tema este precisó el tema de ucrania
está haciendo que es es que se paren los
dos partidos y que aplaudan la labor y
lo que está diciendo el presidente yo
bailé en varias varias cosas noticiosas
entre otros usted lo mencionaba el
anuncio de pues delegar de crear un
cargo de un fiscal que
investigue los fraudes pandémicos los
fraudes de empresas que durante la
administración pasada se aprovecharon de
estos fondos que puso a disposición
administración para las pequeñas
empresas pero que las grandes empresas
por sus habilidades legales y por
conocer mejor la ley fueron las que
terminaron aprovechándose de estos
pequeños préstamos que iban a pequeñas
empresas sobre este tema fue muy
enfático también el presidente yo bailé
él quiere que las grandes empresas
paguen lo justo resaltó cómo muchas
empresas que están entre las 500
empresas más grandes del mundo acá en
eeuu simplemente no están pagando
impuestos y él reiteró varias veces él
dijo él es capitalista pero no se puede
pensar en un capitalismo donde no hay
competencia un capitalismo donde no hay
competencia
precisamente termina generando
oligopolios estos oligopolios terminan
subiendo los precios de los consumidores
que no terminan ayudando precisamente al
tema de la inflación porque suben los
precios de los productos y los servicios
en ese tema por ejemplo fue enfático
también al resaltar lo que se tiene que
hacer para reducir los precios de los
medicamentos en este punto también fue
aplaudido tanto por demócratas y
republicanos porque pues ésta también ha
sido una política que ha tratado de
impulsar administraciones pasadas
republicanas de que las farmacéuticas
pues reduzcan ese poder que tienen haya
más competencia y los precios por ende
disminuyan mencioné el tema de la
insulina y su pues ejemplo aún el niño
que invitó precisamente al estado de la
unión a su discurso como ejemplo de los
altos precios que pagan los
estadounidenses por la insulina y pues
este tema entonces de los medicamentos
desde el poder de las empresas pues fue
recurrente en su discurso obviamente hay
que resaltar también que para responder
concretamente a su pregunta si este tema
de ucrania pues va a unir un poco más a
eeuu va a tratar de mitigar estas
diferencias tan grandes que hay entre
republicanos y demócratas porque
recordemos que apenas hace unos meses
antes de este conflicto china era el
foco de la política exterior
estadounidense y ahora ucrania parece
que pues emitirá estas diferencias entre
republicanos y demócratas
cristóbal gracias por esta información y
le voy a pedir que siga conectado con
nosotros por si volvemos a tener un
reporte desde washington y tal como lo
decía cristóbal vázquez nuestro
corresponsal uno de los momentos en los
que aplaudieron de pie al embajador fue
cuando aplaudieron a la embajadora
ucraniana en eeuu
oksana marcar o va en ese momento los
legisladores los jueces de la corte
suprema- la vicepresidenta kamala harris
y también el presidente joe biden
aplaudieron a la mandataria en una
muestra de respaldo a ucrania ahora
continuemos entonces con un análisis
para entender qué tan importantes son
estas palabras que pronunció en el
discurso y para eso conectamos a esta
hora con flor en frases que son que nos
director del grupo de investigación en
relaciones internacionales
américa latina e integración de la
pontificia universidad javeriana en
bogotá y también está desde ciudad de
méxico roxana juárez especialista en
seguridad nacional y fuerzas armadas y
quiero comenzar con ustedes con un punto
que trató nuestro corresponsal y es la
unión en eeuu frente a la guerra en
ucrania y no en vano el presidente joe
biden comenzó precisamente por este tema
por la invasión rusa a ucrania y
condenándola que tan efectivo puede ser
este tema en la política interna
estadounidense y comencemos por favor
con roxanne
profesión adelante la escucha perdón
perdón buenas noches pues me parece que
fue fundamental hablar de la unión
porque los eeuu en anterior presidente
trump
sabemos que
mantuvo un discurso de división en los
eeuu y esto la verdad eso cabo una serie
de e
estamentos que ya los norteamericanos
tenían dentro de su democracia un
ejemplo de ello porque se está esta
petición que hace vaivén
al derecho del voto como recordarán en
las últimas elecciones que fueron de las
elecciones más votadas en los eeuu hubo
una serie de incidentes en diferentes
estados de la unión de los eeuu desde
esta nación y propició que diferente que
estos estados impulsarán algunas leyes
que de alguna manera entorpece digamos
el proceso electoral entonces este
llamado está este llamado a la unión el
presidente de bailén y está esta
exigencia de que se se haga se revise
este derecho al voto es muy muy
importante y además se cara a una en un
contexto donde hay una guerra en donde
hay
la unión es parte de este discurso en
donde
se está uniendo el mundo en contra de
rusia me parece que es una es un disco
que es un concepto el concepto de unión
lo está usando en ambos en ambos
estadios eso es así que me parece que el
hablar de unión en estos momentos para
bardem fue muy importante la gente está
muy dividida y ahora con el tema de
además de la difícil situación económica
me parece que les pone una mayor una
mayor dificultad en lograr unidad en los
norteamericanos florent y para pasar con
usted quiero hacerle una pregunta
adicional y es usted cree que esta
financiación directa de la que habla yo
bailé de mil millones de dólares para
los ucranianos en ayuda humanitaria y en
ayuda de defensa puede valerle puntos
políticos al interior de eeuu joe biden
o al contrario esto podría aumentarle la
poca o reducir la popularidad que ya
tiene por debajo
yo creo que más allá de la plata que se
podría gastar y sabemos los medios que
tiene a su disposición en eeuu son las
11 oportunidades que puede nombrar en
las cuales el conjunto del congreso se
levantó para aplaudir si iniciando con
casi un minuto de aplausos a la
embajadora ucraniana ante las naciones
unidas así las cosas el presidente de
eeuu está demostrando un liderazgo
liderazgo nacional estadounidense pero
también internacional con una medida que
me parece más relevante aún que el gasto
de mil millones de dólares y es el
desbloqueo de en total 10 por ciento de
las reservas de petróleo de la
disposición de eeuu 50 millones de
barriles al inicio de la semana y 30
millones más que se acaban de anunciar
esto con el fin de estabilizar el precio
internacional del petróleo lo que va
mucho más allá de un gasto destinado a
ucrania sino que no hay a su voluntad de
apoyar a toda costa no solamente a los
estadounidenses para el precio de su
gasolina sino el conjunto de sus aliados
en el esfuerzo que están
cumpliendo para apoyar a ucrania flores
y precisamente algo interrumpo ahí
porque quiero profundizar en algo que
usted ha mencionado usted mencionó los
80 millones de barriles de petróleo y
que esto puede ayudar a reducir el
precio del combustible en eeuu y también
en los países aliados pero precisamente
es por eso que le quiero preguntar como
la liberación de estos barriles puede
impactar a países como los europeos por
ejemplo que dependen tanto de la del gas
y del combustible ruso
en la estrategia de construcción de una
alianza internacional
hayden y eeuu ha tratado de convencer a
los productores de petróleo entre los
cuales los países de la península árabe
de aumentar su producción y no ha
obtenido hasta el momento respuesta
positiva de estos socios conocemos
también la situación con venezuela uno
de los principales productores en el
continente americano así las cosas como
líder del mundo libre tal como se
declaró el mismo durante su discurso
decidió poner a la disposición del
mercado estos barriles con el fin de
limitar las tensiones que podrían nacer
con base en una reducción de la
producción ha estado
rusa
a los estados europeos que son los
principales consumidores a esto es
importante agregar que sin embargo no se
ha declarado a favor de una economía
carbonada es decir que solamente
funcionaría con base en energías no
renovables en este punto es muy
importante porque era una de las
principales quejas de sus contrincantes
republicanos
empujando a toda costa para que la
transición verde no se haga y en este
sentido trató de mitigar tanto el precio
del petróleo a corto plazo como sus
intenciones de llevar eeuu hacia hacia
una transición energética
completa de pronto fue el último el
único momento en el que los republicanos
no se mostraron particularmente ante
entusiastas frente al discurso pero hubo
muchos otros temas en los cuales reveló
su capacidad a unir los estadounidenses
de un proyecto común y finalmente esto
es de pronto lo más relevante de todo en
este momento de crisis en el que
hubiéramos podido esperar unos
estadounidenses políticos pero también
su población extremadamente divididos
dejando aquí un camino abierto no
solamente para putin pero también para
el régimen de jean ping
una muestra de unidad en casa y con los
aliados y ahorita vamos a hablar
precisamente de ese punto frente a la
unidad económica pero antes quiero
preguntarle algo a roxana y es cómo
entender la decisión de joe by del de no
enviar tropas a ucrania sino solamente
de defender el espacio de la otan y esto
frente a dos medidas y es 1 eeuu acaba
de terminar una guerra de 20 años en
afganistán y acaba de salir de este país
del medio oriente y por otra parte la
otan no puede actuar en ucrania pues
este país no hace parte de la alianza
militar como entender entonces que joe
biden no envíe tropas directamente a
combatir contra los rusos en ucrania
bueno ya él dijo en su discurso que él
defendería a la otan en
en su actuar ya en su zona
de
influencia
a mí me parece que
está manteniendo un
una distancia correcta me parece ante
este este conflicto en el entendido de
que la
especialmente la unión europea no
incluyo en la otan a estos países que
bueno era evidente que en algún momento
habría un conflicto como en el caso de
crimea donde pareciera que con mucha
facilidad se hizo rusia desde esta zona
y ahora pensando en que pudiera repetir
en la misma la misma estrategia para
hacerse de ucrania
por desgracia me parece que los
norteamericanos están en una posición
muy compleja porque estas es todas estas
cosas que pudieron haber sucedido como
la anexión de crimea adiós perdón de
ucrania a la otan no pasó la unión
europea se mantuvo bastante distante de
esta situación bastante pasivos y bueno
al grado de que los alemanes mismos
hablando de energía los alemanes mismos
prefirieron sustituir su
energía nuclear con éste con con gas
entonces ahora me parece que están que
están hay una serie de factores que
están distinguiendo en medio de todo
este proceso y los norteamericanos han
preferido mandar es ayudar con este tema
energético que es muy importante del
tema de los barriles para para que no
sufra una mayor presión la unión europea
en el apoyo a los ucranianos
y obviamente el apoyo
misiles y de una serie de armamento que
han estado últimamente enviando hacia
allá y yo a mí me parece que el tema del
envío de tropas va a ser hacer una
estrategia y digamos un plan b en medio
de toda esta de esperando a cómo se
configura el
el tema de ucrania pareciera además en
estos momentos que en los planes de los
rusos no nos salieron como ellos creían
y pensaron que en este ya en estos
momentos esto ya se habría definido a su
favor y yo creo que los norteamericanos
están en espera
yo creo que también es la su su política
interna está marcando los pasos a seguir
de esto y yo creo que además está estela
de cara a las próximas elecciones
intermedias están también dictando los
pasos y la manera como van van ellos a
a participar pero sí es muy importante
entender que también pero que quieren
también tener este liderazgo que como
usted nombró bailan como los líderes de
los países libres
de los países democráticos y sigamos
hablando de un tema que ustedes han
mencionado y es la economía que además
fue el segundo ítem que trató joe biden
en su discurso florent quiero preguntar
algo y es que bailen y sus promesas para
reducir el costo de vida de las familias
trabajadoras y dentro de ellas mencionó
dos puntos que pueden golpear a las
grandes compañías pues él está
defendiendo reducir el precio de los
medicamentos de prescripción y además
sostiene la idea de imponerle un
impuesto del mínimo el 15 por ciento a
las grandes compañías estadounidenses mi
pregunta entonces es esto no puede ser
un golpe a las compañías que pueden
debilitar internamente la política de
joe biden o cómo entender esto
fue el segundo momento en el que el
campo republicano - se manifestó a favor
de lo que estaba diciendo el presidente
de bailén
efectivamente podríamos considerar que
estamos observando aquí de alguna manera
un retorno a una situación anterior a
los años 80 cuando el presidente reagan
con su homóloga británica margaret
thatcher
liberalizaron los mercados disminuyeron
los impuestos de las grandes empresas y
no solamente a un impuesto mínimo a las
empresas sino a una ausencia total de
aumento de impuestos para los hogares
que ganan menos de 400 mil dólares al
año eso se supone entender que todos los
hogares que ganan más de 400 mil dólares
al año van a ver sus impuestos a
aumentar
se agregaron lo que podríamos llamar
medidas
económicas y sociales claramente más a
la izquierda que a la derecha como el
aumento del salario mínimo pero más que
todo en este país que es eeuu el apoyo a
la creación de sindicatos y la
invitación de uno de los sindicalistas
más conocido de eeuu en este momento yo
vergés así las cosas
podemos ver que se propone aquí una
modificación de la orientación de la
acción económica del estado federal de
pronto es en este punto que yo vaivén va
a tener más dificultades para convencer
a los opositores políticos pero es el
lugar en el que más votos puede
encontrar obviamente los
el lector es poco decididos en eeuu son
generalmente a la gente que está
excluida del sistema tal como funciona
bien en eeuu es decir los trabajadores
pobres o la gente que pertenece a
comunidades minoritarias con estas
medidas económicas yo bailén está
claramente haciendo una apuesta para que
las masas de los estadounidenses van a
ver sus condiciones de vida cambiar eso
antes del mes de noviembre es decir
antes de las próximas elecciones y
precisamente como usted lo dice joe
biden está prometiendo que las
condiciones de vida de los
estadounidenses van a cambiar y en ese
sentido dijo una frase que es muy
poderosa y es productos estadounidenses
para eeuu promoviendo el mercado interno
en uno de los países que es uno de los
mayores líderes de la globalización
roxana quiero preguntarle entonces en
ese sentido cómo entender las palabras
de joe bailén cuando dice que deben
equilibrar el campo de juego frente a
china y cuando le pide al congreso que
apruebe la ley de infraestructura que
tan posible es que en eeuu realmente se
consuma lo que se produzca únicamente en
este país
bueno pues como siempre en la política y
en el terreno de los hechos me parece
que hay 22 carreteras y creo yo que
el discurso político de john biden
responde a una necesidad de de mandar un
mensaje de protección en una economía
proteccionista a estas clases sociales
que como se acaba de mencionar son las
que no solamente son las que menos
participan sino que son ahora las más
afectadas con la inflación
y una es casualidad que por ejemplo
mencionado este tema de la de los
medicamentos como la insulina para los
diabéticos porque hay 29 millones de
diabéticos en eeuu entonces creo yo que
este tipo de este discurso de
proteccionismo creo yo que a muchos
norteamericanos se dé cuenta en la
situación marginal les puede caer muy
bien el el una de las quejas más
importantes en los últimos de
los últimos meses y desde que entró
vayan con los resultados que ha habido
pues digo con una pandemia además
qué tan tan importante el que queda
afectado a la economía de eeuu ha sido
esto de que ha mantenido una posición
muy populista entonces espero que no
vean pero los votantes pero sin que los
norteamericanos sientan que su situación
en el tema laboral hayan mejorado
entonces y creo yo que él está mandando
un mensaje absolutamente proteccionista
pero veo yo con mucha dificultad que
esto vaya a suceder porque las las
grandes
los grandes consorcios las grandes
empresas
difícilmente
podrán cerrar cerrarse al mercado ahora
los chinos han sido tan hemos visto en
este proceso de guerra con ucrania los
hemos visto también muy
cautelosos para
marcar su posición desde el primer
momento y creo yo que tiene mucho que
ver con el hecho de que tienen intereses
muy importantes y no van a ellos así
están entonces la voy a interrumpir
porque vamos a escuchar en este momento
cuál es la respuesta que están dando los
republicanos al discurso que dio joe
biden ante el congreso escuchamos y en
unos minutos volvemos con nuestros
analistas invitados que él prometió
cuando tomó la oficina pero no tiene que
ser así siempre hay una alternativa en
todo el país los gobernadores
republicanos y los legisladores están
mostrándole a los estadounidenses como
se ve un liderazgo conservador lo que
significa respetar a la gente a la que
servimos
levantarse por ellos y caminar junto a
ellos sabemos que nuestros problemas
recorren y requieren acciones
contundentes pero sabemos que esto no
significan acciones de gobierno son los
estadounidenses haciendo sus propias
decisiones tomando sus decisiones por
sus familias y por su futuro los
gobernadores republicanos republicanos
también tienen la misma crisis del cobi
19 pero nosotros honramos sus libertades
así que los cierres de escuela y de
empresas llegaron con su propio costo y
lo sabemos y estás obligatoriedad es no
eran las respuestas y escuchamos las
señales especialmente con los niños en
las escuelas lo que sucedió y sigue
sucediendo le a nuestros niños durante
los últimos dos años es increíble la el
aislamiento la ansiedad la depresión
en tantos estados nuestros niños han
sido dejados a un lado y muchos nunca
van a alcanzar a los demás y por eso
requerimos que requeríamos que las
escuelas abrieran sus puertas y me
atacaran a mí por los medios de
comunicación
pero fue no fue una decisión difícil fue
una decisión correcta y mantener las
escuelas abiertas es solo el principio
de la revolución revolución profamilia
que están llevando a cabo los
republicanos tanto en iowa como en otros
estados en este país los republicanos
creen que los padres importan era verdad
antes de la pandemia y nunca ha sido más
importante decirlo fuerte los padres
importan ellos tienen un derecho a saber
y un derecho a decir
que se les enseña a sus hijos las
familias también tienen todo el derecho
de vivir en una comunidad segura y eso
empieza con un país seguro pero la
administración baiden se ha negado a
asegurar nuestras fronteras se niegan a
proveer los recursos a detener el
tráfico humano
a detener el flujo de las drogas
ilegales y mortales y se niegan a
protegernos
con impuestos y yo con los republicanos
los gobernadores republicanos de siete
estados hemos enviado recursos a
nuestras fronteras y también le hemos
dado seguridad a nuestras fronteras algo
que nuestro vicepresidente y nuestro
vicepresidente y nuestro presidente no
han hecho desde que llegaron al poder
los demócratas en washington están
gastando trillones de dólares y enviando
a la inflación al cielo nosotros estamos
cortando los impuestos y equilibrando
nuestros presupuestos porque sabemos que
es mejor que gastar el dinero en
burocracia hoy firmé una legislación que
elimina el impuesto en iowa
a los ingresos y esto es menos de la
mitad de lo que era hace cuatro años
y no debería ser una sorpresa que
estemos entre los estados con la
inflación menor y que la mayoría de
ellos sean republicanos y puede que los
republicanos no tengamos a la casa
blanca pero estamos haciendo todo lo que
pueda para que podemos para mantener el
liderazgo los republicanos estamos
liderando estamos levantando nos por los
padres y por los niños estamos
defendiendo a la vida
estamos manteniendo a nuestras
comunidades seguras y agradeciendo a que
ellos en uniforme estamos luchando para
restablecer la independencia de energía
estadounidense y eso incluye a los
combustibles biológicos y no les estamos
pagando a la gente para quedarse en casa
estamos respetando su libertad detrás de
mí está el capitolio de iowa donde
establecemos nuestro modelo y donde
nuestro mantenemos nuestros derechos y
estas no son son las palabras vacías es
una creencia de que la grandeza de este
estado y de este país cae en nuestro
nuestra gente no en nuestro gobierno no
deberían tener que levantarse cada
mañana y preocuparse porque les va a ser
ahora el gobierno ustedes a sus negocios
oa sus hijos si nosotros como líderes
estamos haciendo nuestro trabajo
entonces el gobierno está funcionando y
trabajando bien estado operando en atrás
está apoyando el espíritu de nuestra
gente no ahogando los está
manteniéndolos a salvar no restringiendo
su libertad y eso es lo que yo creo y
eso es lo que los republicanos creemos y
eso es lo que los republicanos estamos
haciendo yo estoy yo soy bien decía al
ser la gobernadora d a donde la gente
trabaja duro y es patriota nosotros nos
preocupamos y nos cuidamos los unos a
los otros y si nosotros somos lo que
dicen a johann amable pero no tienes que
ser de iowa para ver que estos son los
valores de eeuu de todos los
estadounidenses durante los últimos años
yo he puesto mi fe en la gente de iowa y
no me han decepcionado yo llamo al
presidente a hacer lo mismo a poner su
fe en ustedes en el pueblo
estadounidense que nunca se ha hecho
hacia atrás en su creencia a este país
sin importar de quién por quien esté
siendo dirigido porque ustedes saben
ustedes han mostrado que el alma de los
estadounidenses no se trata de quien
viva en la casa blanca son los hombres y
mujeres como ustedes en cada rincón de
esta nación quienes están dispuestos a
levantarse y a tomar la responsabilidad
por su comunidad por sus vecinos
y por ustedes mismos
por esta medida importante
el estado de nuestro país es fuerte
gracias dios los bendiga y dios bendiga
a los eeuu de américa
escuchábamos aquí reynolds la
gobernadora del estado de iowa y
republicana ella tuvo un discurso mucho
más dirigido a los estadounidenses en
comparación con el que hizo el
presidente joe biden por ejemplo
insistió en que los republicanos
respetaban la libertad y aunque no lo
mencionó directamente se refería sobre
todo a las medidas del joven 19 que en
eeuu han creado una polémica por el uso
del tapabocas a las cuales los
republicanos se oponen insistió en que
ella en que los republicanos honraban
las libertades de los estadounidenses
que los cierres de los colegios y de las
oficinas llegaron con sus propios costos
insistió en que las familias tienen
derecho a vivir en una comunidad segura
y en contraste con lo que dijo el
presidente joe biden quien defendió una
reforma migratoria
la gobernadora reynolds criticó que el
presidente no está manteniendo los
estándares de seguridad de eeuu y esto
se lo adjudicó al hecho de que el
presidente no aseguraba las fronteras
como lo dijo directamente
hasta washington donde estaba nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
explícanos un poco más qué fue lo que
acabamos de ver y qué tan importantes
son estas palabras de la gobernadora
reynolds
esos dos puntos precisamente el punto de
no asegurar las fronteras
recordemos que yo bailé tuvo algunas
pericias durante el pasado año los
haitianos que estaban tratando de entrar
a la frontera la reacción de la patrulla
fronteriza con látigos que generó toda
una crisis en eeuu y el tema del gasto
público lo mencionó la gobernaba el
gobernador a reynolds diciendo que ellos
los republicanos no le pagaban a los
estadounidenses para quedarse en casa y
no trabajar y no estaban gastando
billones de dólares que estaban
contribuyendo a la inflación la por la
posible respuesta o defensa de los
demócratas que incluso yo bailén en su
discurso esta noche lo mencionó es que
por ejemplo sin este gasto público a un
tema que puede sonar simple como lo de
las guarderías para los niños sin es
igual gasto público para financiar las
guarderías el precio a la mitad que
quiere financiar el gobierno a los
padres para que puedan enviar a sus
niños a sus menores a las guarderías sin
eso por ejemplo no permitirían que las
mujeres puedan ir al mercado laboral
muchas mujeres porque las guarderías en
ciudades como washington nueva york o
chicago tienen un costo promedio mensual
de tres mil dólares al mes en promedio
este costo pues llevó a que muchas
madres simplemente prefieran pues dejar
de ir a trabajar a ahorrarse sus tres
mil dólares quedarse en la casa y esto
entonces pues suma a la crisis de la
falta de mano de obra que hay en eeuu y
esto lleva a que obviamente los costos
sean más altos para las empresas que se
traduzcan entonces a los consumidores
finales precisamente porque no hay esa
inversión social en financiar guarderías
para que las madres puedan estar libres
y puedan ir al mercado laboral esa
podría ser entonces una de las defensas
de los demócratas en cuanto a esta
crítica que hacen los republicanos de
que más gasto público pues lleva a más
inflación y pues el tema de la frontera
obviamente se puede refutar por parte de
los demócratas al argumentar que es muy
difícil pues en este momento cuando hay
un conflicto en europa cuando hay una
ola migratoria
y de muchos ucranianos no solamente a
europa sino que pronto se empezará a ver
a eeuu y cuando se retira de eeuu de la
guerra de más de 20 años de afganistán y
eso genera obviamente una ola migratoria
de refugiados también de afganistán pues
hablar de cerrar las fronteras creo que
va en contra del contexto global en este
momento por el que pasa eeuu y por el
rol que debe asumir eeuu como pues líder
del mundo y por la responsabilidad que
tuvo en estos conflictos
gracias cristóbal por este contexto que
nos está dando desde washington y
nosotros seguimos con nuestros invitados
especiales floren france aunque nos y
roxana juárez un poco para poner más en
contexto y en análisis que es lo que
acabamos de ver y quiero volver entonces
con florent para preguntarle uno de los
puntos que no mencionó el presidente joe
biden en su discurso y que relativamente
la republicana estaba atacando y es la
inflación como lo estaba diciendo roxana
el presidente ni siquiera mencionó esta
palabra a pesar de que es uno de los
puntos más criticados durante su
administración
pues en febrero de este año la inflación
aumentó un 75 por ciento respecto a los
dos meses a los 12 meses anteriores esto
frente al precio al consumidor y es el
aumento más grande que ha habido desde
1982 como tener entonces este silencio y
porque joe biden se puede explicar que
no hizo referencia a él
yo creo que sí hizo referencia al tema
de la inflación de hecho no una vez sino
mínimo tres veces en un momento mencionó
que el plan económico que estaba
proponiendo había sido aprobado por 17
recibe
personas que había recibido un premio
nobel de economía y que justamente este
plan tenía como objetivo central de
disminuir la inflación al mismo tiempo
que disminuir la la deuda
aquí podemos siempre discutir
el alcance económico de una propuesta de
gobierno pero claramente lo ha
mencionado hace parte de este paquete
que incluye la liberación de barriles de
petróleo de la reserva
estadounidense hay dos puntos que
mencionó la gobernadora que no abordó
efectivamente en su discurso el
presidente de byd en esta cuestión
el aborto o de la libre elección y el
segundo punto es el de la educación de
los niños de los programas que se
proponen a los niños estadounidenses en
las escuelas específicamente un tema de
mucho debate entre republicanos la
cuestión de la teoría de género crítica
y aquí efectivamente son dos temas que
son lo que yo llamaría el pan y el agua
de los republicanos desde que yo vaivén
todo asumió el el poder sobre todos los
demás temas yo vaivén respondió
propuso una línea de acción
puede haber debate sobre si
efectivamente lo que anunció poder puede
producir los efectos que está esperando
pero por lo menos los mencionó
de hecho el discurso de la gobernadora
era un poco defensivo en algún momento
ella dijo hacemos lo que podemos porque
no estamos en el poder en este sentido
monstruo bailén con su discurso que está
hoy tomando decisiones está orientando
la política de una manera que puede ser
obviamente criticada pero incine está
tomando decisiones como pues se esperaba
que lo hiciera en este discurso de hoy
roxana y vamos con usted sobre sus
opiniones del discurso de la gobernadora
de iowa quin reynolds y le quiero
preguntar por los dos puntos que nos
mencionaba afloren 10 el aborto y la
educación en los niños cuál es la
división que existe entre los
republicanos y los demócratas en estos
dos puntos y por qué en el discurso de
la gobernadora
bueno la
gobernadora
efectivamente el tema del aborto estuvo
ausente en el discurso de biden pero
biden de algún modo me parece que el
tractor de
de atajar digamos este este
esta ausencia hablando de los derechos
de las mujeres eso fue muy interesante
porque le está hablando de este apoyo
por ejemplo para las como le dijo
cristóbal para los apoyos para que las
mujeres tuvieran una posibilidad de
dejar sus de dejar sus hijos en
guarderías y también para que eligieran
su futuro fue muy empático al hablar de
la elección de que las madres eligieran
estos temas de salud y
libremente eligen su futuro me parece
que si uno lee entrelíneas puede ver que
deja un espacio abierto al respecto
aunque no lo menciona aunque él se ve él
no tiene no tiene ganas de de imprimir
una en una posición frontal respecto a
éste a este tema del aborto
y lo de la educación es fue también muy
enfático al hablar de que los niños
tienen derecho ir a la escuela
que era importante que la
gobernadora fue muy enfática al decir al
hablar inclusive de las enfermedades
mentales de los niños en este en esta
época de pandemia entonces me parece que
si va a ir en chile tuvo un está está
este espacio que le dio a las mujeres y
también inclusive al tema de transgénero
me parece que creo crear lee
lo lo deja en una especie de área de
confort para evitar este este tipo de
temas e issste a otra cosa que dijo la
gobernada que me pareció muy interesante
pues el tema el el aspecto del este de
la inmigración este asunto porque
durante él
discurso de biden
no fue muy evidente pero hubo una una
mujer una congresista
grito y los aplausos no
evitaron que se escuchará grito que se
construyera el muro o sea hay una hay
una animadversión respecto a la a este
al tema de la inmigración que como ya se
mencionó es verdad me parece que en un
momento de guerra en donde las
migraciones no solamente las que ya
tenemos
tradicionales y que ahora se han
implementado en estos últimos dos años
con una difícil
cooper con una muy difícil complicada
cooperación con este con el gobierno
mexicano
van a imprimirle una mayor complejidad
del asunto migratorio entonces este
regreso resumo el tema del tema del
derecho a las mujeres en donde fue tan
enfático creo yo que lo dejó abierto
para entender que también podrían estar
involucrando estas cuestiones de salud
que incluyen el aborto y quiero retomar
un tema del que usted estaba hablando y
es la migración que como lo estaba
explicando nuestro correcto en
washington cristóbal vázquez es un tema
que divide profundamente a los
republicanos y a los demócratas y le
quiero preguntar a florent o le quiero
pedir más bien que pongamos en contexto
dos afirmaciones que hicieron tanto el
presidente joe biden como la gobernadora
quin reynolds y de un lado es que el
presidente afirmó que era necesario
arreglar las fronteras según sus
palabras mientras que reynolds está
diciendo que baile no garantiza la
seguridad por no asegurar las fronteras
pongamos estas dos frases en contexto
que tan ciertas o no son
cuando se trata de migración en los
países más desarrollados específicamente
europa y eeuu
hay muchas
y muchos fantasmas se ve mucho miedo en
cuanto a la migración que
fundamentalmente
permite por un lado renovar la población
en términos
simplemente genéticos hay más gente
gente que hace falta con una población
que cada vez es va envejeciendo
y segundo punto permite nutrir la
economía con una mano de obra
generalmente barata y dispuesta a asumir
puestos que los nacionales o ciudadanos
de estos estados no son dispuestos a
asumir así las cosas estamos con la
migración y fundamentalmente en un tema
de política y
contrariamente a una enfermedad como la
comida es normal que tengamos un debate
caldeado
alrededor de la migración
el presidente by den ha sido enfático en
la necesidad de no solamente vigilar las
fronteras de una manera distinta a la
que se viene haciendo desde hace varias
décadas sino también a reformar todo el
sistema legal que
acompaña la migración eso con el fin de
alcanzar un mejor y mayor control en
este sentido cuando hablo de la policía
o de las fuerzas de seguridad del estado
mencionó que no estaba a favor de
disminuir los fondos de la policía todo
lo contrario de aumentar los fondos y en
sintonía con lo que anunciaba sobre las
fronteras de modificar las estrategias y
las prácticas entonces
a tomar este tipo de decisiones se
necesita un apoyo bipartidista para que
leyes nuevas sean formuladas y de pronto
aquí la política se hará más fuerte que
los deseos del presidente de eeuu y
obviamente para los republicanos ver a
bailén fracasar en esto es termina en
este asunto específico de las
migraciones sería una manera barata de
ganar electores para las elecciones de
noviembre entonces siempre ha sido un
tema de mayor relevancia en estos
últimos 20 años en la política
estadounidense podemos esperar que
durante los próximos meses la emigración
se transforme en uno de los puntos
centrales de las campañas el propósito
de que se puede transformar en uno de
los puntos más importantes de esta
campaña electoral estamos en otro
contexto y es lo que estaba ocurriendo
en ucrania si bien la mayoría de los más
de 670.000 refugiados que acnur está
diciendo que están huyendo de ucrania
van hacia los países vecinos que son
polonia eslovaquia hungría moldavia y
rumanía se espera también una que llegue
una cantidad de ucranianos a eeuu que
era como lo decía nuestro corresponsal
roxana le quiero preguntar si frente a
este tema de la posible migración de
ucranianos a eeuu puede haber o no un
consenso bipartidista para apoyar la
entrada de los ucranianos o no
pues a mí me parece que van a tener que
ponerse de acuerdo porque ya hemos visto
la toda proporción guardada ya hemos
visto la experiencia de la de la falta
de cooperación de entre méxico y eeuu
para lograr un acuerdo en donde en donde
se se pueda
introducir personas de otros países y
refuercen la economía de un país que
necesita mano de obra con una población
que está envejeciendo
y bueno y como como mencionó como se
menciona anteriormente son temas que se
quedan en el terreno de lo político
cuando que se podrían con este con más
con más voluntad se podrían solucionar
con él con una serie de revisiones
técnicas de estas poblaciones que van
llegando creo yo que se van a tener que
poner de acuerdo porque el reflector
internacional de un momento como éste es
muy muy importante tiene obviamente por
una cuestión política de este eje o es
del de geopolítica tiene un mayor
reflector la migración
ahora ucraniana que la inmigración
haitiana por equipo por ejemplo no para
si pareciera que tiene dos valores
distintos y pasa un poco con él como con
el tráfico de armas que también lo
mencionó es bailando como tráfico pero
ésta está hablando de vestir restringe
el armamento pero por poner un ejemplo
es otro tema que se queda siempre en el
en la esfera política
es una es un factor de discusión entre
entre ambos partidos cuando se supone
que debería de ser un tema de
de de revisión en este en las leyes en
el terreno de la justicia de la
prevención de la seguridad de muchos
otros en muchas otras esferas
sociales
gubernamentales y no solamente en la
esfera política entonces me parece que
van a tener que hablar y van a poder se
van a tener que poner de acuerdo y creo
que lo van a hacer exclusivamente en el
tema de ucrania por una cuestión de
guerra en el caso de las otras
migraciones que ya tenemos ya tenemos un
es un problema bastante complejo en la
frontera con méxico a mí me parece que
ese es el tema se va a quedar
olvidado pero si definitivamente tendrán
que hablar a hablarse porque él
el reflector internacional es importante
para los europeos bien ver cómo hay una
discusión en medio de una guerra y no
hay una posibilidad de apoyo a las
poblaciones ucrania de los grupos
ucranianos que querrán entrar a estados
unidos como comparen con el que querrán
encontrar en eeuu son refugios y este
consenso también es probable que irradió
otros temas que pidió joe biden y le
preguntó a floren por ejemplo él le
pidió a los legisladores que aprueben la
ley de libertad para votar la ley de
avance de derechos electorales john
lewis y también pidió el respaldo de
ambos partidos en la ley de
infraestructura incluso mencionó la
nominación del fiscal para perseguir el
fraude durante la pandemia y para todo
esto necesitará el apoyo de los
legisladores y los demócratas no tienen
una mayoría absoluta ni en el senado ni
en la cámara de representantes se puede
hablar entonces que este factor
unificador de ucrania puede irradiar
otros proyectos que están promoviendo
los demócratas
si me permite voy a decir unas palabras
sobre la pregunta anterior que tiene que
ver con la migración de los ucranianos
el racismo en eeuu es constitutivo en
muchos aspectos de la identidad de este
país de sus ciudadanos en este sentido
lo que pasó en la frontera con polonia
con inmigrantes o refugiados más bien de
orígenes africanos o sur asiáticos puede
ser como un preludio a lo que podría
pasar en eeuu con los migrantes
ucranianos es decir acoger a los
ucranianos blancos y azules y dejar a
todos los indeseables por fuera está
siendo dicho
un
representante o más bien un senador
fundamento de red fundamental
importancia aquí es el senador joe
manchin que vimos en repetidas
oportunidades
en la primera plana durante el discurso
de yoga y de este tipo de demócratas
conservadores
van a ser absolutamente aquí esencial si
trabajan con el presidente de eeuu
podríamos ver una legislación que iría
en los en el sentido de los anuncios de
los anuncios formulados por joe biden
pero si estos demócratas conservadores
como joe manchin se rehúsan a trabajar
con el presidente de eeuu lo más
probable es que la mayoría de los planes
que estaba anunciando por ejemplo de la
reforma o de la de un mayor acceso al
derecho de voto por parte de minorías o
de personas que han sido excluidas por
haber tenido problemas con la justicia
generalmente la mayoría de los casos se
trata aquí de tráfico de drogas de
microtráfico entonces
los republicanos van a conservar un
rumbo muy claro que es limitar a toda
costa el acceso al voto de las
comunidades excluidas más empobrecidas
las que son a priori votantes demócratas
para dejar una minoría de
estadounidenses generalmente que
corresponden a la identidad uas
blancos anglosajones y protestantes con
un nivel socioeconómico más alto en
capacidad de renovar el mandato de los
republicanos a una vieja tradición en
eeuu jerry mandrin es decir trazar los
condados de voto en función de las
poblaciones que se encuentran en estos
condados eso con el objetivo de
garantizar
el mayor número de representantes en las
distintas
elecciones aquí estamos viendo en
pantalla el líder de los senadores
republicanos uno de los hombres que ha
sido
fundamental en esta estrategia de
recortar los mapas electorales con el
fin de garantizar la superioridad
numérica de los representantes
republicanos en ambas cámaras del
congreso
laurent y para ir cerrando nuestro
cubrimiento especial del discurso del
estado de la unión quiero preguntarle
sobre la conclusión suya frente al
alocución de weyden y precisamente
frente a la última idea que él planteó y
ese estado del estado de la unión es
fuerte porque ustedes los
estadounidenses son fuertes que tanta
polarización o división o por el
contrario unión puede haber realmente en
eeuu en medio de todos estos panoramas
que hemos tratado como la economía la
pandemia y la guerra en ucrania
yo creo que yo bailé no hizo
relativamente bien
como lo dije al inicio
recolectó el apoyo general del congreso
en 11 oportunidades
tenía el ojo
particularmente puesto en su fraseología
su capacidad a mantener durante una hora
un discurso particularmente coherente
de una cierta manera
convincente para todos los que lo
estuvieran escuchando y el viejito
solamente se tropezó dos veces en una
hora mientras estaba hablando este punto
puede parecer anecdótico pero ha sido
particularmente subrayado por sus
opositores políticos y la cadena de
información foxnews quién
en su en su gran mayoría orienta las
percepciones del público estadounidense
entonces si bien hubiera podido de
pronto ser más
tajante sobre algunos temas como lo
mencionó la profesora juárez
específicamente el tema del género
transgénero de las mujeres de las
participaciones de las minorías en
general en la economía yo creo que lo
hizo relativamente bien y de pronto
veremos en las próximas semanas esto
reflejarse en un cambio así sea mínimo
en las encuestas de opinión
roxana y qué conclusiones tiene usted
del discurso que dio el presidente joe
biden ante el congreso de eeuu
río del doctor que creo que lo hizo lo
hizo bien me parece que no hizo en
algunas cuestiones que podrían ser
polémicas a mí me parece que
él se ha mantenido muy cauteloso en su
posición de cara a las elecciones entre
intermedias y en esta misma cautela la
ha reflejado con esta falta también con
con su con la manera como está se está
manejando el conflicto con ucrania ha
sido muy contundente pero por otro lado
ha sido cauto cauto en en hacer
movimientos demasiado
drásticos entonces este ahora me parece
que él estará
esperando cuáles cuáles van a ser los
siguientes pasos con ucrania que creo yo
que
además de esta protesta proteccionismo
que de alguna que que hoy dejó muy claro
me parece que también es la la guerra de
ucrania será una un motivo más para
lograr una ventaja con sus adversarios
políticos
definitivamente estancarse en esta carga
política que tanto necesita
que tanto necesita que se vea en donde
se ve que es el que le dé un beneficio
en los próximos para poder salvar zanjar
los próximos dos años de su de su
gobierno y lo miraremos sobre todo en
las elecciones de medio término que
también ayudan a medir la popularidad
del presidente y agradecemos a roxana
juárez por estar con nosotros desde
ciudad de méxico y también a floren
fransson que nos quien está en bogotá
gracias por este análisis y por este
completo panorama que nos entregan de lo
que fue el discurso del estado de la
unión que dio el presidente joe biden en
eeuu también agradecemos a nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez por darnos toda la información
especialmente un agradecimiento a
ustedes por estar conectados con
nosotros los invitamos a que sigan en la
señal de france 24 que nosotros en
minutos les traeremos más información de
la actualidad internacional